jour particulier qui est ce 5 novembre
puisque le 5 novembre celle anniversaire
jour pour jour de la remise du rapport
gallois au premier ministre qui a
précédé de peu d'heures puisque dès le 6
novembre a été annoncée le pacte pour la
croissance la compétitivité et l'emploi
eh bien les décisions qui ont été tirés
immédiatement par le gouvernement de ce
rapport rapport qui a été
exceptionnellement suivi puisque vous
savez que la tête quasi totalité en
réalité des propositions faites par
monsieur gallois ont été prises en
compte par le gouvernement il se trouve
que hier je l'accompagnais produit sera
saint-etienne pour un déplacement
organisé à l'occasion de l'anniversaire
de ce pacte avec arnaud montebourg fleur
pellerin geneviève fioraso donc c'est
adapté plus qu'adapter de venir en
parler avec vous et de faire un premier
bilan je vais faire une petite 1,6
puisque vous avez évoqué le sujet
monsieur le président sur la situation
européenne
puisque il se trouve que aujourd'hui la
commission européenne a rendu ses
prévisions de croissance de déficit de
finances publiques et il est important
d'en connaître les résultats que distel
je le dis mais intel graphique
premièrement la zone euro qui va
connaître encore la récession en 2013
sort de la récession il ya cette année
huit pays qui seront en récession en
2013 il y en aura deux seulement l'année
prochaine et donc le taux de croissance
de la zone euro regarde positif
s'agissant de la france et c'est
important au moment où encore une fois
nous sommes dans l'examen du projet de
loi de finances les prévisions de
croissance que nous avons faites sont
validés la commission européenne dit 0
2% en 2013 c'est un peu plus que ce que
nous avons annoncé que nous sommes sur
0,1 enfin désormais le consensus est
plutôt déplacé sur 0,2 c'est ce que dit
le fmi c'est ce que dit la commission
européenne c'est ce que dit l'insee
comme prévisions pour cette année ça ne
conduit pas à changer nos prévisons de
croissance mais je dis que là nous avons
été tout à fait prudent notons car c'est
important que avant l'été c'est à dire
au mois de juin
les chiffres de la commission européenne
était à -0 un tel consensus des
économistes était à -0 3 conclusion de
tout ça nous sommes déjà sur un rythme
de croissance de 1% aujourd'hui annuel
avec un profil à pau orthez deuxième
trimestre qui était très bon un
troisième qui le sera probablement un
peu moins et un quatrième qui marque sur
saône est de l'activité je prends à
témoin un chiffre qui est les chiffres
nous avons connu hier de reprise du
marché automobile à la fois renault ce
qui n'est pas nouveau et psa aussi qui
est repassé dans une situation plus
favorable enfin la commission européenne
10 09 pour 2014 et le même chiffre que
nous
là encore je pense que notre x
prévisions et prudente et 1,7 en 2015 à
27 c'est un chiffre de croissance qui
permet cette fois ci des créations
nettes d'emplois qui permettent de faire
en sorte que l'inversion de la courbe du
chômage soit durable et est un contenu
plus important en emplois marchands tout
ça valide une stratégie à la fois
européennes et nationales européennes
je viens devant vous régulièrement
depuis 18 mois il ya un an la question
qu'on se pose est ici au début de
l'examen du projet de loi de finances au
sénat s'était est-ce que l'euro va
survivre est ce que la grèce va rester
quelques nuits que j'ai passé au mois de
novembre et décembre 2012 est-ce que
chypre
être consolidés est ce que tout ça ne va
pas introduire arrive défaisance '
l'euro nous avons fait face cette année
des programmes ont été mis en place les
réponses nationales ont été apportées la
banque centrale européenne donnait les
signaux utile et je veux le souligner
ici monsieur draghi eu des paroles
importante c'était l'été
mille doses quand il ya des whatever it
takes trouvant dit en bon français quoi
qu'il arrive nous ferons ce qu'il faut
pour
sauver l'euro la chose ont été sécurisés
et désormais et la pérennité et
l'intégrité et la stabilité de la zone
euro sont garantis et du coup cette zone
euro sort de la récession dans ce
contexte la france fait mieux que la
zone euro en 2013 est en ligne pour 2014
et en 2015 devrait retrouver des niveaux
de croissance qui sont au niveau de
croissance plus conséquent et donc la
sortie de la récession elle est faite et
la reprise s'annonce crédible solide à
nous de faire en sorte qu'elle soit
solidifier et je disais il ya la
dimension européenne il ya aussi la
dimension nationale 1 animaux sur la
dimension européenne qui devait évoquer
des pays hors zone euro j'imagine
peut-être vous faisiez allusion au
royaume uni qui c'est vrai les taux de
croissance actuellement plus
spectaculaire mais notons quand même
qu'il faut toujours raisonner en base et
qu'il parte un point qui est plus bas la
france elle va retrouver le niveau de
croissance y'a pas s'en glorifier à la
fin 2013 qu'elle avait en 2008 elle sera
le deuxième groupe i l'union européenne
à le faire après l'allemagne nous sommes
très loin de cette situation au royaume
uni qui a connu des performances
macroéconomiques extrêmement médiocre
pendant les cinq années où a duré la
crise et puis il ya les facteurs
nationaux et ses facteurs nationaux
c'est que la politique qui est suivi est
sérieuse à la fois sur le plan des
finances publiques le redressement des
finances publiques car
la commune urbaine note aussi notre
trajectoire de déficit 5,3 en 2011 suite
été à nouveau 5 23 ans de didot si nous
n'avions pas pris les mesures
d'ajustement nécessaires c'était 4,8 4,1
en
2014 2013 et en 2014 nous serons à 3,6 à
3,8 sommes dans l'épaisseur du trait et
nous serons en dessous de 3% en 2015 je
tiens à le dire d'ailleurs puisqu'il ya
une petite ambiguïté là sur ce sujet là
et commission européenne dit 3,7 mais
résonne en conventionnel sert sans
prendre en compte que mesures
d'ajustement supplémentaire déjà prévue
pour 2015 et donc nous sommes tout à
fait sur la trajectoire seront à 3,6
cette année parce que je maintiens ces
chiffres en deçà de 3 en 2015 et dans
tout çà ou là de la macroéconomie au
delà du redressement des comptes publics
il y a l'ambition économique du pacte de
compétitivité sur lequel maintenant je
veux arriver parce que c'est l'acte
économies majeures je dirais fondateur
de la politique économique de quoi par
le pacte d'abord d'un diagnostic de
déficit de compétitivité de la france
que nous avons établies était notre
arrivée aux responsabilités pendant la
campagne présidentielle ça avait déjà
été le montrer parole prison ne
rapplique je rappelais que à l'époque
celui qui était candidat avait dit le
premier chapitre ça doit être le
redressement productif et la première
proposition de la création de la banque
publique d'investissement et puis
j'avais moi même adressé ce et dressé
aussi devant vous lors de nos troupes
mais échangent ou les comptes de la
france en juin 2012 l'occasion du débat
d'orientation sur les finances publiques
est évidemment louis gallois a étayé
d'un très solide ce nouveau stick et sur
la base du diagnostique compression nous
avons défini des voies d'action qui nous
permette de redresser la compétivité
commis française tout en restant fidèle
à une ambition réformiste en particulier
j'ai la conviction qu'il est possible de
renforcer le tissu productif français de
garantir son
l'insertion harmonieuse sur le long
terme dans les échanges mondiaux grâce à
une compétitivité que j'appellerais
positive et pérenne basée non pas sur
l'écrasement des salaires
l'accroissement des inégalités le moins
disant social mais sur l'investissement
l'innovation et la productivité vous
évoquez le plus bas monsieur le
président il ya ce soir je veux
participer à un débat à l'assemblée
nationale la commission des affaires
économiques cette fois ci c'était là une
plénière en fait
délocaliser 30 commission docteur
économique en présence de louis gallois
il disait il faut miser sur l'innovation
la montée en gamme et pas l'austérité je
fais bien de cette formule en effet ce
n'est pas le moins disant social ce
n'est pas les inégalités ce n'est pas
l'écrasement des salaires qui sont la
solution mais c'est bien tu sais bien
une attitude beaucoup plus aujourd'hui
alors quels sont les ingrédients clés de
cette compétitivité positive nous le
mettons en place depuis un an d'abord un
cadre fiscal qui soit favorable à
l'investissement l'innovation pour
permettre aux entreprises de se doter
d'outils plus performants
ensuite une organisation du travail
améliorées grâce à la réforme du marché
du travail une véritable stratégie
d'investissement par la puissance
publique une réglementation qui
améliorent l'environnement des
entreprises un financement de l'économie
qui répondent aux besoins des
entreprises à la fois en matière
d'endettement et en matière de fonds
propres tout ça pour quoi faire pour
grandir pour former pour innover hier je
ne citais premier ministre à
saint-etienne il a dit nous ne faisons
pas de cadeaux aux patrons nous faisons
en sorte que les entreprises puissent
investir investir pour développer la
croissance et de la sorte pour pouvoir
embaucher l'idée c'est au final
d'améliorer la productivité globale de
l'économie qui a ralenti dans la
dernière décennie nombreuses économies
avancées donc de redresser notre
compétitivité oui à une politique qui
est une politique de l'offre n'est pas
exclusive d'une action sur la demande et
sur le pouvoir d'achat pouvoir d'achat
qui s'est renforcée de ma très
significatif du fait de la chute de
l'inflation dans la zone euro qui
étaient les niveaux et historiquement
faible 0,7 0,8 point pour cette année
mais
il ya bien cette amélioration de l'offre
productive qui est une volonté du
président de la république qui est
l'action du gouvernement et donc il ya
une action qui est menée à la fois hors
coûts et sur les coûts sur les coûts il
ya le coût du travail grâce aux cice je
vais y revenir il ya le coût de la
recherche développement avec la
consolidation et l'extension du crédit
d'impôt recherche
que je revendique tout à fait je pense
que ça nous permet de résorber
progressivement notre cap en matière de
recherche développement d'innovations ya
le coût du financement interne et
externe grâce à la réorganisation en
profondeur du financement de l'économie
n'est pas loin du financement l'économie
je mentionnerai la réorientation des
parts dans les entreprises la création
de bpi france la création du pe à pme
dans le cadre du plf 2014 que vous
examiner toutes ces politiques qui
agissent sur l'offre productive elles
ont une caractéristique c'est qu'elles
doivent s'inscrire dans la durée elles
ne peuvent produire d'effet
que dans le temps long pour pouvoir être
intégré dans nos éditions des
entreprises pour porter leurs fruits et
donc il ya un mouvement de rénovation
de réforme des structures économiques du
pays grande ampleur en même temps qui
conforte notre modèle social mais ces
outils s'inscrivent dans le temps long
et notamment monsieur gallois avait
demandé le président de la république a
confirmé la sanctuarisation d'un certain
nombre de dispositifs fiscaux parmi ceux
ci je veux mentionner le crédit d'impôt
recherche qui est tout à fait
fondamental pour maintenir
l'attractivité la force la créativité
nos entreprises donc si vous laisse sur
le message général que j'aurais qu'on
retienne c'est que le pacte de
compétitivité c'est un choix politique
c'est une orientation de redressement de
l'offre productive et c'est une
orientation que je ne vois pas quel
gouvernement le prix avant nous dans
cette ampleur nous ont fait ce choix
parce que nous pensons que la
compétitivité des entreprises c'est
l'intérêt de la france et c'est une
fille née l'intérêt de sa jeunesse voilà
la logique générale je vais maintenant
au bilan sur lequel vous interrogé le
président premier élément a signalé une
majeure c'est que la très grande
majorité des 35 mesures du pacte
présenté il ya un an à d'ores et déjà
été mises en oeuvre et louis gallois
puis on a testé le mot président la
république je commence par le cic eux
c'est la mesure phare que nous avons
mises en place de manière accélérée avec
le soutien la présentation nationale
plusieurs remarques à sion 1
nous sommes engagés dans un exercice de
transparence absolue quant à
l'utilisation du cicr par les
entreprises et un comité de suivi
partenariale qui était mise en place
pour la bonne information de la
représentation nationale vous y êtes
rattaché nous vous devons cette
transparence deuxièmement ce comité de
suivi a rendu un rapport qui certes est
encore préliminaires mais qui montre que
la montée en puissance du dispositif et
rapide le taux de recours devrait être
de 90 7% l'an prochain et que les
entreprises s'approprient pleinement le
dispositif de lui un bruit de fond que
certains ont cherché à entretenir il ya
quelques mois sur la supposée complexité
du cic veut en fait ce que révèle le
rapport du comité de suivi c'est une
appropriation déjà très forte du cic par
les acteurs économiques c'est tout à
fait conforme à ce que me disent les
chefs d'entreprise que je rencontre
régulièrement sur le terrain relevons et
c'est le troisième point que les
premiers travaux d'évaluation confirme
qu'une part importante du cic eux
bénéficié à l'industrie savais qu'il y
avait eu ce débat sur est-ce qu'on va
plus haut que 5 smic jusqu'à 3 5 smic
ciblant d'industrie où est ce qu'on va
plus bas privilégiant l'emploi et les
services nous avions choisi un compromis
2.5 smic eh bien ça touche l'industrie
puisque le dispositif bénéficie en effet
autant de 20% l'industrie c'est beaucoup
plus que la part de l'industrie dans
l'économie française
et je parle uniquement de l'effet direct
ce qui a un effet en quelque sorte de
second tour c'est à dire que ça va
bénéficier à l'ensemble de l'économie
par son impact sur les autres secteurs
sous la forme d'une baisse des prix des
consommations intermédiaires n'oublions
pas qu'aujourd'hui services et industrie
sont étroitement liés je pense que ça
n'a pas de sens en vérité de les opposer
et ça c'est aussi de la baisse des prix
qui se diffuse dans l'économie troisième
remarque catherine remarques sur le
séisme le montant des préfinancements
progresse avec constance aussi je vais
entendu chiffres donnés un ancien
premier ministre avait dit 430 millions
d'euros tout mouillé nous sommes déjà
environ un milliard pour des pays france
un fin septembre ya plus de dix mille
dossiers de préfinancement qui avait été
reçu par dpi france pour un montant de
920 millions d'euros +2 58% des prenait
des petites entreprises et là encore
faut pas confondre cice et
préfinancement toutes les entreprises
donc pas besoin de préfinancement le
prix de financement ailleurs un coût non
il est fait pour celles qui ont des
besoins de trésorerie pour pouvoir
bénéficier du cic veut et donc la
plupart des organismes s'accordent à
dire que cice qui est assise sur la
masse salariale pour 2013 a déjà eu un
effet incitatif dès 2013 et qui leur a
permis de créer des emplois ou de
prévenir des destructions d'emplois de
l'ordre de 30 mille emplois c'est
l'hypothèse de rang tout cas inscrits
par l'insee dans sa note de conjoncture
l'insee étant comme vous le savez à
l'institut de prévisions indépendant
enfin le rapport du comité de suivi
c'était important pour un moment beau
comme pour moi souligne qu'à la suite
des actions du gouvernement au printemps
et des consignes qui ont été données les
abus des entreprises donneuses d'ordre
dans le cadre des relations
contractuelles ce qu'on a pu appeler le
racket au cic de tout ça est en train de
disparaître et plus de recours en la
matière devant le médiateur
interentreprises à l'heure où je vous
parle et c'est un effet positif des
messages des consignes qui ont été
données en même temps le pacte pour la
compétitivité c'est sans doute d'abord
le cicr mais ce n'est pas que le celi
ses voeux je m'arrête sur deux piliers
du pacte pour le financement des
entreprises et l'innovation le
financement des entreprises ça ça m'a
beaucoup mobilisé pendant la première
année de mandat est avec vous gevrey à
une mobilisation massive de financement
la destination des entreprises dans le
cadre du pacte compétitive et je garde
d'ailleurs un très bon souvenir
2 tu es débat que j'ai eues ici au sénat
puisque on était bien au delà de la
majorité sénatoriale pour adopter aussi
bien le bpi que la forme bancaire sur
lequel nous avons eu vous en souvenez
monsieur le président je crois des
débats de qualité vous les avez souligné
comme tel bpi france a permis
d'accompagner près de soixante mille
entreprises sous les 9 premiers mois de
l'année 1,5 milliard d'euros de
trésorerie a été injecté dans l'économie
grâce au dispositif de pré financement
du cce du crédit impôt recherche et du
dispositif de trésorerie offert par la
bpi une vraie bouffée d'oxygène pour nos
entreprises en matinée les pme qui le
disent
notons aussi que l'encours de crédits
aux sociétés françaises non financières
est joué quasiment stables alors qu'ils
se contractent dans la zone euro donc il
ya un financement jeu
n'ont pas généreux mais solide de
l'économie enfin les entreprises se
financent à l'heure actuelle à des
niveaux historiquement bas
inférieur à la moyenne en zone euro
y compris pour les pme qui se financent
en moyenne 90 points de base moins cher
que la moyenne en gros là aussi c'est la
reconnaissance signature solide de la
france le souvient de petite musique on
attendait au début de ce mandat
attention la france va décrocher et
quand elles n'ont donc spreads se sont
plutôt réduit depuis le bilan par
ailleurs on a engagé le chantier ouvert
pour des lois d'un meilleur accès des
entreprises au financement de marché et
pour le lire plus globalement à des
sources de financement autres que
bancaire
il évolution qui est inéluctable devant
nous et on le sait on va passer à un
système plus d intermédiaire il faut
donc progressivement tout en gardant
secteur bancaire tout son rôle et nous
l'avons réforme et sortir les
entreprises relation unilatérale avec
les banques il ya eu des réformes
engagées en ce sens là je mentionne la
réforme du code des assurances
qui a déjà permis d'améliorer entre 5 à
10 milliards d'euros de l'argent géré
par les assureurs et la dette
d'entreprise et la réforme de
l'assurance vie qui sera présenté dans
le cadre du finances rectificative en
sera une autre concernant l'innovation
c'est le deuxième pilier que je voulais
souligner vous avez relevé que nous
sommes dans une démarche d tamise
d'approfondissement des mesures du pacte
de compétitivité le plf 2014 va
permettre de lancer un nouveau pays à
hauteur de 12 milliards d'euros qui est
un dispositif incitatif du budget il est
financé par un versement du budget
d'état vers le comté de perdre du trésor
en 2014 12 milliards de dépenses
budgétaires sans changer
pour autant le besoin de financement de
l'état les décaissements sont ensuite
étalé dans le temps par une montée en
puissance des appels à projets du pays à
2 à partir de jeux de fin 2014 en relais
du pays à 1 pour des décaissements à
partir de juin 2014 et surtout
le pays à deux est aussi financé par une
gestion active et responsable du
patrimoine de l'état je réponds à votre
question monsieur le président comme
annoncé par le premier ministre des
cessions de participations contribueront
au financement du pays à deux ailes ce
qu'on fait là encore dans le temps tout
comme les décaissements du programme le
solde sera intégrée aux besoins de
financement de l'état et donc l'impact
sur les finances publiques de tout ça
est limité grâce à des modes de
financement vertueux des prêts de ciment
fonds propres créer des actifs pour
l'état qui ne compte pas c'est que
monsieur qu'elle voyait très attachés
dans le déficit maastrichtien ici des
avances remboursables qui ne lieu des
retours financiers qui viennent diminuer
le déficit maastrichtien enfin il est
dotation non consommables qui ont animé
un impact limité au montant annuel des
intérêts et au total des subventions
sont en fait limité à 32 % du programme
total in fine et l'impact des
investissements d'avenir ne serait que
de 4,7 milliards d'euros entre 2014 et
2017 sur la dette de 3 8 milliards
d'euros sur le déficit ce qui montre
l'efficacité de ce financement j'en
viens à l'investissement
avec d'autres mesures comme le statut de
jeune entreprise innovante
je me suis rendu il ya peu de temps en g
aux côtés de daniel raoul et quelques
autres nous avons lancé la mesure
aujourd'hui les incitations ou les
exonérations sont dégressives elles
seront maintenues pendant huit ans et
deuxièmement le dispositif est étendu
aux dépenses d'innovation stricto sensu
ce qui permettent de s'approcher du
marché ce qui est un problème essentiel
pour ces jmj
l'impact des mesures que j'évoque sera
amplifiée par le plan innovation élaboré
par geneviève fioraso et fleur pellerin
présenté hier par le premier ministre
aujourd'hui par les ministres
il s'articule autour de quatre objectifs
promouvoir l'innovation pour tous
notamment en sensibilisant tôt les
élèves aux enjeux de l'innovation
encourager l'innovation ouverte en
particulier au travers des changes a crû
entre laboratoires publics et privés
mobiliser l'innovation pour la
croissance en renforçant la communauté
des acteurs qui finance innovation enfin
mieux évaluer les politiques
d'innovation public dans ce cadre l'état
poursuit son effort de financement de
l'innovation des convictions le fonds
national d'innovation sera doté de 240
millions d'euros pour financer
l'innovation sous toutes ses formes
protéger aussi le savoir-faire français
de plus 1,1 milliard d'euros sera
mobilisée par des fonds le
capital-risque spécifiquement dédié aux
entreprises innovantes et de croissance
voilà mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs quelques remarques je
souhaitais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui
je pense sincèrement que ce pacte de
compétitivité complet qui commence à
porter ses fruits que nous avons suivi
un calendrier vigoureux de déploiement
de ces mesures je sais en même temps que
rétablir la compétitivité qui avait été
fortement dégradés est une entreprise de
longue haleine qui va mobiliser le
gouvernement et la représentation
nationale là aussi dans la durée et en
même temps j'ai une conviction absolue
comme ministre de l'économie et des
finances et les deux vont ensemble
c'est que
cette approche de la compétitivité
elle est notre meilleure chance pour
l'économie pour l'emploi pour
l'investissement et qu'il faut
résolument continuer dans ce sens du
renforcement de notre offre productif en
même temps que nous adressons nos
comptes publics
je sais que
représentation nationale et le sénat
damman sera vigilant sur sa mise en
oeuvre je suis évidemment toujours à
votre disposition pour aller plus loin
monsieur le ministre
nous allons à présent
et appartient de l'exposé que vous avez
fait vous poser quelques questions et à
tout seigneur tout honneur n'est ce pas
le rapporteur général va vous poser des
questions à la fois amicales mais je
pense qu'ils iront aussi un peu au fond
des choses
président si sept
seigneurs en tout cas c'est un honneur
de pouvoir interroger aujourd'hui le
ministre pierre moscovici
je remercie d'ailleurs de son exposé
assez exhaustif c'est vrai que nous
sommes aujourd'hui à date anniversaire
en gros sur la mise en oeuvre d'un
dispositif qui avait été initiée suite
au rapport gallois nous avons auditionné
monsieur gallois nous avons eu le
sentiment qu'ils avaient de nombreuses
pistes intéressantes
et et je remercie d'ailleurs le ministre
et ses services des éléments de réponse
détaillée qui nous ont apporté ces
derniers jours dans le cas de notre
réflexion sur ce sujet dans le cas de la
préparation de l'homme discussions
budgétaires qui ne saurait tarder séance
publique au sénat
je note aussi dans les précisions qui
ont été donnés que le
préfinancement du cicr qui est la mesure
phare de l'ensemble de ses trente et
quelques mesures mises en oeuvre par le
gouvernement à
eu un écho favorable puisque vous
l'indiquez monsieur le ministre
on avait fixé à la bpi un objectif de
800 millions d'euros pour le
préfinancement du cic eux nous lançons
aujourd'hui à quelques semaines de la
fin de l'année civile à plus d'un
milliard et à onze mille deux cents
dossiers s'ils me chiffres sont exacts
la fin octobre c'est donc dire que
l'objectif est atteint voire dépassé que
les banques ont été aussi sans doute
contribuer même si on a du mal à
recenser
les éléments d'information utiles cet
égard mais une première question peut
être
nous vient à travers les commentaires
qui ont pu être faits et les éléments
qui apparaissent dans le rapport du
comité de suivi du crédit d'impôt pour
la compétitivité et l'emploi
que nous avons pu
à voir ces derniers jours c'est un
rapport d'octobre et celui ci porte sur
la sectorisation de cet outil et en
particulier sur le questionnement
récurrent est ce qu'on est d'assez
l'industrie les entreprises
exportatrices
c'est une question qu'il est naturel de
se poser mais vous l'avez dit vous-même
au-delà des chiffres bruts il faut tenir
compte des effets de second tour une
expression que les élus connaissent bien
et il y a dès lors un renfort
substantielle de la contribution à
l'industrie dès lors que l'industrie
bénéficient de prestations émanant de
sociétés de services de sociétés en
amont et on a bien sentiment que
l'industrie bénéficie assez largement du
dispositif les sociétés exportatrices
aussi mais au demeurant la question est
simple est-ce que s'ils ont souhaité
recentrer le cic e sur l'industrie les
secteurs exportateurs de manière encore
plus significative
les règles de droit européen le
permettrait-elle c'est une question je
pense sur lesquels on peut réfléchir
quelques instants
j'évoquerai ensuite en deuxième point le
thème de la compétitivité
et j'ai noté relativement à cette
question de la compétitivité dans les
éléments d'information que nouveaux
services nous devons apporter ce
ministre que
sur les investissements directs
étrangers entrant la france se situe
devant l'allemagne en stock comme en
flux et je note que la france se situe
devant l'allemagne sur huit des dix
dernières années pour les
investissements entre ans ce qui donne à
penser que ces investisseurs
internationaux qui regarde l'europe ont
tendance à considérer que la situation
de la france
reste tout de même relativement
compétitive pour l'accueil des
investissements entre ans et je note
d'ailleurs que d'après le gru cède les
flux d'investissements entrants se sont
établies à 20 milliards d'euros en
france en 2012 en baisse de 8 milliards
par rapport à 2011 ce qu'on peut
expliquer par la conséquence de la crise
mais de seulement 5 milliards d'euros en
allemagne quatre fois mois en baisse de
30 milliards par rapport à 2011 donc je
crois pouvoir constaté l'ats d'après les
chiffres donc officiel qui nous sont
communiqués que la france conserve une
position qui n'est pas nécessairement
la plus défavorable à tous égards on
pourrait même
dire quelque part le contraire et je
voulais vous poser une question à cet
égard puisque il est envisagé
que en allemagne
on puisse disposer prochainement d'un
accord sur les salaires
et que en l'occurrence
le différentiel de compétitivité entre
la france et l'allemagne pourraient s'en
trouver modifié
puisque dans le cadre du pacte de
coalition il est probable que soit
institué un salaire minimum national de
8,5 euros bruts par heure et la question
qu'on peut se poser quelle est votre
appréciation sur ce point le ministre
qu'elle serait à prévenir vu les
conséquences en matière de compétitivité
quelle est votre position ce qui
concerne aujourd'hui ce débat européen
sur l'émergence de cette ambition d'un
smic européen
quelles sont les avancées prévisible de
ce point de vue
j'en viens au delà de ces questions aux
pme puisque bien entendu c'est un sujet
de préoccupation pour nous tous et j'ai
bien noté que la décision numéro 32
avaient visé à accompagner le
développement des pme de croissance
innovantes en mobilisant l'achat public
différent mesures ont été prises je vais
pas les recenser mais je crois qu'il ya
de nouvelles mesures sur l'innovation
des pme qui sont annoncés qu'ils l'ont
été hier vous avez évoqué ce sujet il ya
un instant mais il me semble que nous
avons tous à être vigilants pour que les
pme puissent bénéficier de conditions
optimales pour cet effort d'innovation
nous appelons tous de nos voeux
peut-être pourriez-vous préciser un peu
plus dans le détail en quoi ces
dispositifs sur l'innovation la
recherche et l'accompagnement le
financement spécifique
de corporate venture qui
peuvent être mises en place à travers
ces nouveaux dispositifs peuvent être
une réponse appropriée à cette attente
des pme aujourd'hui
deux dernières questions si vous voulez
bien monsieur le président la première
sur l'outil que constitue la garantie
des crédits de trésorerie aux
entreprises c'est un outil que la bpi a
mis en place depuis le début de l'année
elle dispose pour ce faire d'une
enveloppe de 500 millions d'euros et il
semblerait que ce produit est été
particulièrement demandées par les
entreprises est ce qu'il faut en déduire
que les banques commerciales
deviennent plus frileuses où cela
traduit-il une dégradation de la santé
des entreprises françaises c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser et j'aurais
tendance à poser la question
relativement au contexte le bancaire
puisque la fédération dépend que nous
avons rencontrés pas plus tard que jeudi
dernier le seul président nous a dit
mardi dernier nous indiquait que ben il
y avait aujourd'hui recul de la capacité
d'intermédiation bancaire et que
bien
on devait s'attendre à des effets
pervers de toutes ces réglementations
européennes aujourd'hui 3 et hop et que
il y avait sans doute des effets
à attendre peut-être pour vous apporter
quelques points et enfin dernier point
sur la fiscalité ma question porte sur
les assises de la fiscalité des
entreprises en 2014 est ce que vous
pourriez
préciser de quelle façon le parlement
sera associé à la réflexion autour de
cette recherche aujourd'hui deux
objectifs
ambitieux concernant
les conditions de fiscalité qui vont
être mises en place d'une façon durable
avez vous souhaité nous souhaitons aussi
avec une visibilité pour toutes des
entreprises et une durabilité de ce
dispositif fiscal comment le parlement
sera
associé à ce travail c'est important
travail de mise en place d'un dispositif
fiscal pour les entreprises voilà
monsieur président quelques sujets sans
doute merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur général ce n'est pas
exhaustif je voudrais me permettre une
dernière et très bref question sioniste
dans son dernier avis public le haut
conseil des finances publiques a estimé
c'est ce qu'il nous dit et que le crédit
d'impôt
compétitivité emploi ne permettrait pas
de créer 90 mille emplois ce qui est la
prévision du gouvernement et il a étayé
son raisonnement en rappelant que les
effets d'un crédit d'impôt ne peuvent
pas être équivalents à ceux d'un
allègement de charges
j'aurais souhaité connaître votre
réaction vis-à-vis de cette analyse
livrée par le haut conseil est
vous demandez ce qu'il y a de vrai dans
les commentaires que l'on entend ici ou
là selon lesquelles le gouvernement
envisagerait
peut-être de modifier les modalités du
crédit d'impôt pour
précisément le
transformer en un allègement de charges
pure et simple alors il ne s'agit
naturellement pad annonces du
gouvernement et de commentaires issus
parfois de milieu que l'on peut
considérer comme bien informée donc
comme c'est vous qui par définition est
le détenteur de l'information serait
utile que vous puissiez nous dire ce
qu'il y à devraient le cas échéant dans
ses commentaires
bien
d'abord l'édition de l'union a pourtant
général certes me calmer pointue et en
effet comme toujours
quelques
petits plus éléments de réponse d'abord
sur chose l'industrie et l'engagement du
séisme
dans son premier rapport le comité de
suivi a m'a montré que les gains pour
l'industrie pour le commerce était
similaire
et abatteuses moment-là ça interroge sur
faut-il centrer davantage sur
l'industrie ou pas c'est un débat qui
pourra se poursuivre dans les années qui
viennent coup sur des travaux du comité
de suivi mais ce qui est clair c'est que
le séisme un double objectif ils étaient
dessinés comme ça soutient la
compétitivité des entreprises notamment
industrielles et aussi soutenir l'emploi
les bas salaires le débat il a eu lieu
pour mon temps comme c'est considérable
sera 20 milliards en 2014 la question
c'est est ce qu'on va jusqu'à 3 5 smic
effet industrie où est ce qu'on tape
plus bas qu'à y avait un effet emploi on
a tapé dans quelques surtout milieu et
moi de parler comme ça en visant à la
fois l'industrie et les services et je
le répète en tout cas pour ce qui me
concerne je pense que c'est la bonne
mesure nous avons besoin dans ce pays de
notre industrie forte je ne me
satisferai pas d'une france sans usine
d'une france sans industrie je vois même
et lui d'autres territoires 13
industriels le pays de montbéliard je
n'imagine pas que nous sacrifions notre
industrie en même temps n'opposons pas
industrie et services et nous avons
aussi besoin d'avoir des services
notamment des services associés
l'industrie qui soient puissants et je
pense que à l'heure actuelle nous sommes
dans le cadre puisque nous avons tout de
même les entreprises industrielles qui
perçoivent 20% du bénéfice du cic eux
alors qu'elle ne pèse que 13% ce qui
trompe eu valeur ajoutée totale de
l'économie les entreprises exportatrices
comme vous l'aimez souligné reçoivent
environ les deux tiers du montant du
crédit d'impôt
et si la barre se limite à un peu moins
de 10 % pour les grandes entreprises
exportatrices c'est simplement parce que
ça correspond à leur part dans l'emploi
marchand total et au delà de ces
statistiques qui vous sont familières et
qui je pense sont parlantes genou a
insisté sur les effets de second tour
cher au président marigny les
entreprises les plus exposées la
croissance bénéficie indirectement des
baisses de prix dans les secteurs les
moins exposées la base de prix c'est
aussi la compétitivité et parmi les
entreprises non exportatrices le séisme
peut leur conférer un coup de pouce
décisif qui leur permet justement
d'accéder à
l'international vous avez soulevé un
directeur un autre problème qui suit de
la grande distribution il faut s'assurer
en effet que le bénéfice du cissé ne
sera pas capté de se traduire par des
emplois ou par des baisses de prix
je ne pense pas que la solution soit
trouvée dans une taxation spécifique du
secteur en revanche il faut absolument
s'assurer que les mécanismes qui en cas
des relations commerciales entre la
grande distribution les fournisseurs
fonctionne correctement
nous nous y employons nous sommes en ce
moment même en pleine négociations
commerciales annuelles entre la grande
distribution des fournisseurs et ce qui
me remonte sur
mon bureau depuis le terrain c'est que
la guerre des prix continue qui a encore
des pme l'agrément agroalimentaire qui
souffre donc il faut agir il s'agirait
avec ministre délégué à la consommation
pour que négociation soit plus
équilibrée et c'est d'ailleurs un des
objets de de la loi amont que de fixer
une règle du jeu plus claires et
renforcement considérable des moyens de
sanctionner les déséquilibres des
relations commerciales
vous m'interrogez sur
le pacte de coalition en allemagne il
est probable pas fait je crois que nous
avons encore probablement
un mois un mois à attendre pour avoir un
gouvernement a - au moins d'après les
informations dont je dispose parce que
chez eux l'acte que constitue le pas de
coalition est en réalité tout à fait
codifié presque notarié mais il n'y a
pas de d'interstices bon je pense
toutefois que ce sera la coalition il
n'a pas d'autres disponibles les
tentatives ce serait des élections en
allemagne qui ne profiterait à personne
je pourrais pas électoralement mais sont
une perte de temps mais ce sont les
allemands qui vous former cette
coalition
il est vrai que la question de
l'instauration d'un salaire minimum est
porté par le spd il est vrai que c'est
la priorité essentielle aux parties il
est vrai alors qu'il est vraisemblable
que cela arrivera et si c'était le cas
je pense que c'est de nature réduire les
inégalités et à soutenir la demande
intérieure et c'est une contribution
possible de l'allemagne alors il faut
être déséquilibres
internes à la zone euro dans un sens qui
soient favorables à la croissance de
cette zone vous avez vu des notes qui
ont fuité du trésor américain sur
l'allemagne ne fait pas mienne mais
c'est vrai que la question qu'elle
soulève c'est la question de l' approche
plus coopérative de croissance en europe
et du fait que les pays qui ont des
excédents doivent contribuer à leur
place à la croissance des autres la
croissance des autres contribuant à son
tour à leur propre croissance il faut
créer ce cercle vertueux là sur le
préfinancement du cic eux je partage
votre appréciation sur le fait que le
dispositif bien fonctionné mieux
qu'attendu un point cependant car il
faut se dire les choses dpi france a
tenu dépassé son objectif folan saluer
mais du côté des banques privées la
mobilisation a été plus tardive j'en
tire deux conclusions pourraient bien
c'est que nous avons bien fait de créer
des pays france et la seconde c'est que
le mécanisme de préfinancement se
poursuivant les prochaines très
important que les banques privés
montrent davantage en puissance il faut
maintenir sur elle la pression sur
l'innovation et les mesures sur les pme
beaucoup a été fait notamment sur
l'achat public pour lequel il ya mme
dimanche changement de culture à opérer
sur les mesures du plan innovations
annoncées il n'ya pas le premier istres
je m'en tenir au sujet de mon ressort si
vous me permettez les sujets financiers
l'objectif c'est de renforcer le
financement des pme de croissance de
niveaux d'action au niveau public
mobilisation de 1,1 milliard d'euros par
deux fonds spécifique de bpi france
sur certaines filières comme les
écotechnologies l'autre sur le capital
développement pour
prendre la 2 exemples très important et
très fort l'idée c'est d'avoir des
participations de 10 à 30 millions
d'euros dans des pme pour les amener à
devenir des deux pays parce que c'est de
ça dont nous manquons au fond c'est de
ce match quand nous avons des grandes
entreprises le leader mondial beaucoup
sont très présentes à l'international
nous avons aussi l'amarante pme il nous
faut consolider le tissu des outils
exportatrices innovantes c'est comme ça
qu'une nation redevient compétitive et
aussi il ya le niveau d'action privé
l'objectif étant de constituer une sorte
d'industrie financière de l'innovation
en france et à cet égard il y aura en
loi de finances rectificative une
proposition de nouvelles mesures pour
inciter les grandes entreprises à
investir dans des pme qui font 15% de
recherche et développement sera un
dispositif d'amortissement fiscal je
présenterai dans quelques jours
l'objectif c'est augmenter de plus de
30% ce mode de financement des start up
en france sur les assises de la
fiscalité elle vise à mettre à plat les
grandes questions qui se posent à propos
des principaux impôts pesant sur les
entreprises pour moderniser la fiscalité
pour adapter la structure de la
fiscalité
l'organisation est encore à parfaire
serait inspiré des assises de
l'entrepreneuriat avec des groupes
thématiques présidée par des
personnalités qualifiées proche du
milieu de l'entreprise je vous en dirai
un peu plus dans quelques semaines mais
il ya une chose qui pour moi est très
clair c'est qu'il faut impliquer
fortement les parlementaires à la fois
dans les groupes de travail au sein d'un
comité de pilotage et coordination
quand je pense ou parlementaire je pense
en premier lieu il faudrait qu'on
définit des mesures aux présidents des
commissions des finances et rapporteurs
généraux des commissions des finances
assez de
beaucoup y ont l'ont demandé il sera
fait droit j'allais dire de manière tout
à fait naturelle ces assises débuteront
à la fin de l'année et se déroulera
jusqu'au printemps de l'année prochaine
pour quoi faire pour faire en sorte
qu'on puisse anticiper sur le bnf 2015
la manière la plus claire
il fut dix épisodes divers des épisodes
sans concertation c'est très malheureux
des concertations qui n'ont pas abouti à
cette année pas tout à fait aboutie et
quand ça n'aboutit pas il faut agir
l'année prochaine l'objectif c'est
d'avoir un dispositif qui soit prêt en
amont de façon à pouvoir construire la
partie fiscalité des entreprises du
pélem 2015 sur une base consensuelle et
c'est une tâche que nous partagerons
avec les parlementaires
sur les travaux du conseil je respecte
totalement le haut conseil sa tâche
principale il faut la rappeler tout
c'est
se prononcer je vais porter extrêmement
ventes puisqu'il peut entraîner
d'inconstitutionnalité sur la
trajectoire
de croissance celui trajectoire des
finances publiques en second lieu il
peut par ailleurs donné un certain
nombre d'avis ou d'opinion sur le sujet
pour ma part je dis que le crédit
d'impôt est un allègement de charges je
note que le comité de suivi déjà dit
qu'il avait au creu éviter de détruire
30000 emplois donc je pense que nous
serons tout à fait sûr le rite et 90000
qui était indiqué et s'agissant de la
transformation du cic est le signe que
c'est une mesure qui est pour le
quinquennat et c'est très important que
les entreprises puissent anticiper dans
la durée après s'il ya des adaptations à
réaliser
il faut compter sur nos réflexions son
coût du travail et sur les travaux du
comité d'évaluation mais c'est une
mesure qui doit s'inscrire dans la durée
ce qu'au fond c'est ce que je retiens
moi de ses 18 mois
dans ce secteur toujours important
délicat qu'est la fiscalité c'est qu'à
un moment très important c'est d'être
capable de construire de la stabilité de
la lisibilité notamment pour les
entreprises pour l'investissement parce
que je répète que c'est ça la ligne
directrice en tout cas de cette partie
la polygamie que je défends ce soir
agir pour que les entreprises puissent
investir pour muscler la croissance et
stimuler l'embauché
si beaucoup monsieur le ministre un de
ses réponses
très très direct à nos différentes
questions et maintenant je suppose qu'un
certain nombre de collègues ont souhaité
vous interrogez j'ai tout d'abord une
demande de parole d'eric doligé oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre je peux dire que avant d'entrer
dans cette salle j'étais très pessimiste
et à vous entendre je suis devenu très
optimiste et je veux dire que monsieur
marc en a remis une couche si j'ose dire
et ma joie intérieure est totale en ce
moment effectivement comme j'ai entendu
parler de redressement productif
le redressement compétitif et cetera bon
je me dis que finalement je devrais
venir plus souvent dans cette salle pour
écouter la bonne parole
le problème c'est que moi je
vis sur un territoire où il ya des
entreprises où il y avait des
entreprises et je regardais tout à
l'heure le journal de mon voisin enfin
celui qui n'est plus là et de ce soir
journal du soir et qu'ils avaient en
grande manchette la france frappée par
plus de mille plans sociaux en un an et
je constate que sur le territoire d'un
département je n'ai jamais vu autant et
en ce moment ça tombe tous les jours si
j'ose dire des plans sociaux en grande
quantité avec des entreprises
importantes
et de plus en plus d'entreprises qui
connaissent ces difficultés et on me
répond mais vous inquiétez pas il ya un
délégué au redressement productif sur le
territoire et tout cela va s'arranger et
en plus on vient de nous mettre un délit
wade hui où je ne sais plus ce que c'est
quelqu'un qui est chargée des
investissements de plus de 3 millions
sur les territoires et l'on a le
sentiment que nous
collectivités nous sommes de plus en
plus mis de côté et que l'état vient
voir les entreprises en difficulté et
que les choses se passent entre bercy et
le territoire et qu'on n'est même plus
avisés des problématiques voire parfois
même les préfets ne sont pas visés des
difficultés que connaissent des
entreprises et que connaissent merci
alors moi je pense qu'il ya là un vrai
problème c'est bien de mettre des choses
en place mais quand on voit les
résultats on peut être quelque peu
quelque peu inquiet alors vous avez dit
il faut anticiper dans la durée pour les
entreprises on est tous d'accord je
pense que les entreprises demandent de
l'anticipation et de la durée
problématique c'est que lorsque l'on
regardé lorsque l'on écoute les
syndicats professionnels voir les
entreprises qui doivent venir
s'implanter en france oui j'ai entendu
qu'il y avait 20 milliards
d'investissements et qu'on était quatre
fois plus fort que l'allemagne mais
quand on écoute les emplois pris à la
demande de la stabilité fiscale en ce
moment j'entends dire par les
entreprises qu'elles ont quelques soucis
en matière de stabilité fiscale
ce soit une stabilité nationale une
stabilité locale puisque localement il
ya aussi des hausses sur le terrain donc
il y à t'il
des conditions pour anticiper la durée
pour les entreprises j'ai entendu parler
aussi de la mobilisation de l'achat
public c'est bien de mobiliser l'achat
public mais faudrait-il encore que les
collectivités la capacité de passer les
marchés et actuellement nous connaissons
également de grandes difficultés sur le
territoire les collectivités baisse
alors ça c'est pas un chiffre que vous
nous avez donné mais baisse le niveau de
leurs investissements alors sur les 20
milliards dont a parlé tout à l'heure
notre collègue marc j'aimerais savoir ce
que cela comprend pas ce qu'on nous dit
à 20 milliards d'investissements
étrangers comme il l'a dit de façon
assez synthétique est ce que ces 20
milliards uniquement dans l'industrie où
est ce que ces 20 milliards
quand on compte le club de foot paris
saint-germain quand on compte le qatar
qui achètent des immeubles etc etc donc
tout ça est intéressant il serait
peut-être intéressant à connaître mais
probablement que que je veux je me
trompe totalement et que ça doit être
uniquement dans l'industrie en tout cas
je l'espère mais je dois vous dire
qu'entre vos discours qui est très
intéressant qui remonte le moral et puis
entre ce que l'on vit au quotidien
je crois qu'après demain on va
d'ailleurs à bercy pour discuter d'une
très grosse entreprise qui a des grosses
difficultés
et je ne vois je n'ai pas vu depuis un
certain temps un seul redressement se
faire sur notre territoire et je n'ai
pas vu depuis 20 ans conclut je fais
large une seule fois un responsable de
l'état qui venait implanter une
entreprise sur notre territoire donc je
suis très surpris de ces changements de
méthode qui met les collectivités
sur la touche donc si l'on veut avancer
il faut avancer tous ensemble mais pas
ceux d'hier il ya l'état d'un côté puis
les collectivités veulent vivre elles
vivent leur fils je suis désolé de mais
peut-être que vous allez me remonter à
nouveau le moral c'est toujours en dents
de scie ces choses là et l'important
c'est de partir avec le moral
plutôt que partir avec quelques
inquiétudes
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
si les interventions doivent être en
dents de scie ou varié je vais à présent
passer la parole à monsieur le ministre
edmond hervé merci dieu présent je me
dis je voudrais tout d'abord vous dire
que j'adhère totalement à votre discours
et j'ai trois points a évoqué vous avez
cité le cas de certaines entreprises de
l'agroalimentaire j'insiste sus certaine
nous connaissons les voix qu'il faut
suivre concernant ces entreprises
agroalimentaires qui
qui peinent
première voie c'est la valeur ajoutée
bon nombre d'entreprises dans ce secteur
n'ont pas su pour différentes raisons
saisir l'importance de la valeur ajoutée
deuxièmement il est important que nous
reconstruisions des filières sans fil
hier il n'y a pas d'avenir mais une
concurrence effrénée qui débouche
nécessairement sur une certaine
mortalité et puis il est aussi important
de dire qu'il n'ya pas en france que les
grandes centrales commerciales vous avez
cité l'allemagne l'allemagne est le pays
dans lequel le commerce de proximité est
le plus développé et monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues lorsque
j'évoque le commerce de proximité je ne
cite pas ce qu'on appelle
traditionnellement les circuits courts
c'est deux choses totalement différentes
je pense aussi que il y a un travail de
repérage un faire concernant les
entreprises et là il me semble que les
établissements consulaires ont un rôle à
jouer
lorsque j'évoque travail de repérage
c'est voir quelle est l'entreprise qui
est susceptible de se développer on sait
et d'autre part travail de repérage cela
concerne la succession des managers au
moment de certaines transitions c'est un
point qui est extrêmement importante et
puis
dernière interrogation je m'interroge
sur l'utilisation qui aujourd'hui est
faite par certaines entreprises y
compris de l'agroalimentaire des
résultats des centres de recherche et
d'innovation
il est important qu'il y ait des
passages qu'il y ait des passerelles
qu'il y ait un dialogue et nous savons
tous que c'est ce temps de passage qui
est extrêmement important parce que plus
il est court plus elle est efficace
deuxième type de questions lorsque l'on
s'interroge que vous le faites sur
l'allemagne et les pays nordiques
qu'est ce que nous constatons nous
constatons qu'il ya eu un basculement
fiscale des entreprises sur les
particuliers et à ce poids j'aimerais
que vous nous disiez quel est votre
sentiment sur un engagement du candidat
françois hollande
relatifs au rapprochement de la cg et de
l'hyères pp je dois vous dire monsieur
le ministre que je suis un ferme
partisan de ce rapprochement et dernier
point concernant les collectivités
territoriales collègue l'a évoquée
n'oublions pas que les collectivités
territoriales représentent aujourd'hui
près de 12 ou 15 % du produit intérieur
brut et ce sont des commandeurs et des
passeurs d'activités tout à fait
exceptionnel d'autant plus qu'il y avait
besoin je vous remercie beaucoup
monsieur le ministre monsieur prison et
beaucoup un monsieur edmond hervé la
parole est à monsieur yannick botrel
merci monsieur le président une
intervention va dans le même sens que
celle d'edmond hervé et vous avez évoqué
monsieur le ministre les relations
commerciales entre la grande
distribution et les industriels
il est vrai que il y a là un
déséquilibre
qui n'est pas sans rapport aujourd'hui
avec les difficultés que peuvent
rencontrer ça et là des entreprises
agroalimentaires je veux dire aussi que
c'est un sujet récurrent lors de
l'examen de la loi de modernisation de
l'agriculture c'est un sujet qui a été
beaucoup beaucoup évoqué est du reste
sur sur tous les bancs
et
dénoncer d'une certaine manière
par les uns et les autres alors en dépit
des intentions de rééquilibrage qui ont
été affichés alors on a le sentiment que
rien de probant n'est n'est sorti de
cette loi et il avait été en particulier
mis en place un observatoire des prix et
des marges dont je ne doute pas qu'il
qu'il fonctionne mais non je n'ai pas
perçu qu'elle était véritablement la
production et l'influencent de sa
production sur la situation que je viens
de décrire mais la vraie cause évoquée
par edmond hervé ne tient elle pas
n'hésitez pas dans le fait que
la france ne compte que cinq ou six
centrales d'achat là où dans d'autres
pays voisins l'allemagne en particulier
il y en aurait plus plus d'une centaine
et que donc
ces centrales d'achat adossé au même
nombre d'anciennes ne font que quoi
qu'il advienne et quoi que l'on tente
semble-t-il la concentration des
référenceurs fait leur jeu et que le
risque est grand pour les références et
dès lors qu'il y à un conflit ou une
discussion aux mêmes qui peut jaillir
entre eux
cela nécessairement se retourne contre
le référent c'est parce qu'il n'a pas la
capacité de résister à ses enseignes et
à tel point d'ailleurs que on dit que
sur
les marges arrière pratiquées qui
étaient pratiquées par la grande
distribution gestion certains époque on
aurait même en la matière elle aurait
même en la matière trouvé la parade aux
dispositions qui ont été prises pour
éviter cela donc voilà le sens de ma
question est celui à savoir si dans ce
déséquilibre qu'il y a dans les
relations commerciales il peut être
envisagé des solutions tout à fait
concrète merci beaucoup chers collègues
le sujet que vous avez abordé est l'un
des thèmes chers au président jean
arthuis mais qui va peut-être intervenir
sur une autre question
vous avez
merci monsieur le président je suis
confus je n'ai pas pu
bénéficier de ces paroles
qui portent à l'optimisme et et à la
confiance mais le témoignage
d'eric doligé
est un grand réconfort pour moi
notre collègue botrel vient d'évoquer
une question j'avais déposé un
amendement
sur un texte
récent et qui était la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale et le ministre chargé du
budget mais assuré que cet amendement
pourrait être utilement repris
accueillie favorablement par le
gouvernement dans le cadre de la loi de
finances ou de la loi de finances
rectificative il s'agit de contenir ses
opérations mais qui permettent à la
grande distribution de percevoir des
marches arrières liquidée dans des
officines qui sont en suisse ou en
belgique
peut considérer que ces pratiques sont
sont contestables et
en effet je vais je vais déposer à
nouveau cet amendement mais je voulais
vous demander monsieur le ministre si
vous ne rêvez pas pour le pilotage des
finances publiques de d'agréger elle
plfss et le projet de loi de finances
pour
permettre à chacun d'entre nous et
peut-être aussi au gouvernement d'avoir
une vision plus claire plus cohérente de
l'ensemble des dépenses publiques et des
prélèvements obligatoires car
bon on voit qu'il y a finalement deux
discussions sur les prélèvements
obligatoires l'une à l'occasion du plfss
l'autre à l'occasion du plf et que ce
n'est pas une bonne méthode pour
s'efforcer de d'orienter les
prélèvements obligatoires et sur les
prélèvements obligatoires
revenons sur l'agroalimentaire je
voudrais souligner les risques de
délocalisation d'élevage dans l'ouest de
la france en particulier et
naturellement de la disparition d'un
certain nombre d'entreprises
agroalimentaires
récemment nous avions un débat sur les
délégations de demandeurs entre les pays
d'europe de l'est et notamment la france
ou l'allemagne et on voit bien et ceci
se vérifie en bretagne
nous avons aujourd'hui des agents et qui
sous le couvert de prestation de
services internationale
intervienne dans les travaux publics
dans le bâtiment et dans le bâtiment
monsieur le ministre vous alliez
observer ce qui se passe dans nombre de
commandes publiques dont la maîtrise
d'ouvragé est assurée par l'état ne
soyez pas déçus
c'est vrai aussi dans l'agroalimentaire
je puis cité le cas d'une usine
abattoirs de porcs en mayenne à évron
groupe socopa
bigard fleurs d'ouvriers est à 10 euros
supérieurs à leurs d'ouvriers dans une
usine dans un abattoir allemand est donc
là on a un vrai risque et tirant les
conséquences de cette situation ne
croyez-vous pas que dans les réformes
des prélèvements obligatoires que nous
pourrions articulé et en est une qui
pourrait consister à l'heure de la
mondialisation à cesser de taxer la
production c'est vrai pour les charges
sociales taxer la production s'est
organisé la délocalisation
pensez vous que nous puissions avancer
dans cette voie et substituer à l'impôt
qui affectent la production and impôts
qui porterait sur les produits et qui
par conséquent serait neutre quel que
soit le lieu de de production de ses
produits mis sur le marché en france
si beaucoup au président jean arthuis
monsieur le ministre voilà beaucoup de
sujets auxquels vous allez vous efforcer
de répondre j'aurais souhaité in fine et
revenir en quelques mots sur une
problématique que vous avez vous même
évoqué et qui est celle
du financement des entreprises par le
système bancaire
françois marque est rappelé que la
semaine dernière nous avons eu comme
nous faisons périodiquement une
rencontre avec le bureau de la
fédération bancaire française qui a
naturellement une fois de plus appelé
notre attention sur l'évolution des
normes européennes et globale en matière
de solvabilité des banques en matière de
liquidités des banques
ceci conduisant selon nos interlocuteurs
à faire évoluer progressivement mais
irréversiblement le modèle de
financement de l'économie française
vers une situation où l'intermédiation
bancaire perdrait du terrain au bénéfice
du financement direct des fonds propres
des entreprises par les marchés et cette
analyse semble assez imparable
compte tenu de la rigueur des normes qui
vont s'appliquer dans les années qui
viennent et que les acteurs
professionnels ont plutôt intérêt à
anticiper
ma question porte monsieur le ministre
sur la cohérence de la politique fiscale
est actuellement conduite avec cette
évolution de fond
lorsque les dividendes font l'objet de
prélèvements fiscaux lourd
lorsque le régime fiscal de l'assurance
vie
est en cours de réexamen
et que ce réexamen est susceptible de
déboucher sûr
des dispositifs différents et
et d'autres exemples pourraient être
prises lorsque la taxe sur les
transactions financières ne trouve
réellement à s'appliquer que sur les
transactions qui portent sur des actions
est beaucoup plus difficilement sur
d'autres produits financiers est-ce que
l'on organise pas et un effet et un
biais défavorable de compétitivité pour
nos entreprises sachant que la structure
du financement de l'économie française
est elle même très spécifique par
rapport à celle qui peut prévaloir sur
d'autres territoires au sein d'états
européens voisins et amis voilà monsieur
le ministre beaucoup de préoccupations
de fond que les uns et les autres ont
exprimé et ce rendez-vous cette libre
discussion me semble particulièrement
utiles comme le seront sans doute ces
assises
portant sur la problématique de la
fiscalité des entreprises et bien
entendu si tel ou tel d'entre nous est
appelé à y participer
nous ne nous déroberons pas vous pourrez
toujours compter sur les sénateurs en
particulier membres la commission des
finances pour avancer tranquillement
calmement dans ces problématiques
je commence par ce dernier point pour
vous dire que c'est pas si vous le serez
j'en prends l'engagement c'est une manie
quelque chose qui était évoquée par le
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale cette sensibilité a été
entendu et la réponse qui sera apporté
c'est qu'il y aura en effet et dans les
groupes de travail et dans un comité de
pilotage et coordination et
représentants des deux assemblées à
commencer par les présidents des
commissions des finances et les
rapporteurs généraux dans le rôle
institutionnel qui contribueront
utilement ces travaux il faut en effet
que l'association se fait en amont est
donc un engagement très précis que je
prends devant vous il reste encore à
fixer maquette le calendrier on discute
aussi avec les acteurs eux mêmes parce
qu'on peut pas réformer la fiscalité des
entreprises contre les entreprises
c'est un fait il faut maintenant que les
entreprises acceptent des réformes
nécessaires
répondre là dessus damman
président arthuis
aussi bien monsieur doligé que jean
arthuis je veux dire que je suis pas là
pour faire du béni oui-oui ou de la
méthode coué ou dire tout va bien je dis
ça parce que je serais pas contre onze
en face de l'ironie entre nous sur ces
sujets là ya pas de dérision à voir on
est sur des sujets extrêmement grave et
extrêmement lourds qui touchent des
hommes et des femmes sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire et sur lesquels nous
nous battons élus de droite élu de
gauche mois jusqu'à ce que je disais que
mes des finances étaient présents une
agglomération vous voyez où elle est
vous voyez ce qu'elle subissait est-ce
qu'elle subit encore la crise de
l'automobile et le sel nombre de boîtes
pour lequel on s'est battus directement
avec mes équipes là encore toutes
sensibilités politiques confondues mais
dis donc je ne cherchais pas insufflé un
optimisme idiot je ne suis pas dans
cette optique là j'ai je suis invité par
vous pour parler de des effets du pacte
de compétitivité ce que je vous dis
c'est que nous avons déployé un ensemble
de mesures sans précédent
extrêmement
étendue et qui portent leurs fruits mais
je sais aussi ce qu'est la situation
des plans sociaux aujourd'hui quand vous
dire que par un coup de baguette magique
et parce qu'il ya eu le pacte de
compétitivité de tout est fini pas du
tout évidemment ils sont des remarques
qui concerne peut-être directement mon
collègue arnaud montebourg mais je suis
à ses côtés on est solidaire personne ne
nie la difficulté personne ne nie qu'il
y a des plans
sociaux nous vivons les plans qui sont
aussi le résultat de sa qualité de
certaines mutations économiques il y en
a est ce que nous nous efforçons de
faire c'est quand il ya des plans c'est
répondre et notamment dans le cas de mes
compétences pour ma part j'ai porté à
l'assemblée un projet loi d'habilitation
pour simplifier la vie des entreprises
qui permettra de porter une ordonnance
pour par exemple réformer le droit des
faillites avec deux orientations inciter
ou procédure amiable pour éviter le
redressement judiciaire et améliorer la
situation des créanciers pour pousser
les banques à apporter des financements
en accompagnement des restructurations
nous débloquons des moyens financiers
gouvernement se bat c'est normal puis à
pied ici et des coordinations sur le
sénateur doligé peuvent être améliorées
avec les élus locaux du commissariat
mais les commissaires correspond
productifs sont là pour ça mais il ya
deux semaines la ministre qui sera à
votre écoute sur ce terrain là voilà
donc pour cette audition de pierre
moscovici le ministre de l'économie et
des finances qui était auditionné par la
commission des finances du sénat
commission présidée par philippe marini
ils étaient auditionnés à propos du
pacte de compétitivité vous pouvez bien
sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes les
auditions sur notre site publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez-vous de l'activité
parlementaire et bien cet après midi à
16h30 avec delphine girard à propos du
projet de loi sur l'économie sociale et
solidaire